hello and good morning we begin with
some breaking news that's just coming in
the last few minutes we're hearing uh
from the mayor of that's in the west of
ukraine that there have been five
targeted missile strikes on the city
this morning that's uh lev the country
the city in the west of ukraine that's
been seen as a safe place for many
people fleeing the war in the east
that's as the country's president warns
the russia wants to destroy the donbass
president vladimir zelensky said that
the aim was to wipe other cities in the
region off the face of the earth
well the standoff for control of the
besieged city of mario polk continues
russia says there are two and a half
thousand ukrainian soldiers holed up in
an industrial complex around the steel
plant thus the last known pocket of
ukrainian resistance in the city the
ukrainian forces say they are standing
firm and will continue to hold out
against the capture of the city
russian troops are preparing for an
offensive operation in eastern ukraine
in the near future they want to
literally finish off and destroy the
donbass destroy everything that brought
fame to this industrial region
russian forces are destroying mariupol
they want to wipe off the face of the
earth other places and other cities in
the dunyest and luhansk regions
well if mario paul falls the city of
odessa could be one of the next targets
for russia let's go to the city where
jason farrell is standing by for us this
morning good morning to you jason so can
we clear up what we understand is
happening over in mary of poland
how about the rest of the fighting for
that eastern part of the country
yeah well obviously we just had this
news of these missile strikes in la vie
which is much further to the west but
places like this do continue to feel
under threat and even though the
flagship the mosque of a ship was sank
off the coast uh here is still tension
in this region because uh there are
still 20 warships out there able to fire
missiles the commercial ships remain in
the dock there's about 80 commercial
ships that can't leave the southern port
because of the blockade there is still
intelligence and sabotage operations
here and there's still shelling into the
town of mikalai of just 70 kilometers up
the road from here there are without
water and electricity at the moment that
have been so for about five or six days
and we're hearing from intelligent
sources here that there might be plans
for a false flag operation between
mikolive and kursan which is down to the
south with the russians claiming that
there's been a missile strike on curson
because they want to hold a referendum
there for people to vote for a people's
republic of curse on so that becomes
independent from ukraine so there are
still huge tensions as you say the focus
really on mariupol with just a few uh
remaining troops
hanging out there and if that does fall
as it's expected to then obviously the
focus will be as elsewhere as those
troops are able to be released uh to
continue their aggression in other parts
of the donbass
okay jason for now in odessa thank you
for that
well the family of a man called sean
peter pinner a former british soldier
who'd been fighting with the ukrainian
army and was paraded on russian
television after being captured in
maduro poll say that their working with
the foreign office to ensure his rights
as a prisoner of war are upheld
the family say that the 48 year old
decided to relocate to ukraine four
years ago and joined the ukrainian
marines they also said they want to make
it clear that he's not a volunteer or a
mercenary now the family released a
statement last night in it they said
that sean enjoyed the ukrainian way of
life and considered ukraine as his
adopted country for the past few years
they went on to say that during this
time he met his ukrainian wife who was
very focused on the humanitarian needs
of the country
sean is a funny much-loved
well-intentioned husband son father
brother and friend to many we're hoping
for a quick resolution to allow sean to
return to his family they also add in
there the name of aiden aslan he's
another british man who has been
captured by russian forces in the past
few days asking for both them to return
safely home
now the home secretary has hit out at
critics of her plan to send asylum
seekers to rwanda for processing writing
a joint article in the timed newspaper
with rwanda's foreign minister vincent
beruta priti patel said we are taking
bold and innovative steps and it's
surprising that those institutions that
criticize the plans fail to offer their
own solutions
well let's take you live to doverner
where dover now where our ashna huranag
is standing by first ashna good morning
to you so pretty patel hitting out at
those institutions who's she talking
about
yeah good morning kamali i mean it's no
doubt that this plan is bold as the home
secretary references in that article
this morning um but innovative many
would disagree with she is very much
standing by her plans but she is
directing those comments to human rights
groups to numerous charities the united
nations perhaps even and a number of
labour politicians who are criticizing
this plan there is growing opposition a
growing feeling of how controversial
this is but i think in some ways the
government would deem this controversy a
good thing people are talking about it
at least and in tying in with you know
the brexit britain policies that they
came up with and the manifestos that
they ran on it is
tying in with very much the perception
that a lot of people have however you do
have this growing opposition including
crucially from the archbishop of
canterbury
not holding back on his language
yesterday in his in his easter sunday
sermon dedicating that and we're used to
seeing justin welby
criticizing political um decisions or
commenting on political matters but this
language was incredibly direct um
calling it uh it's calling this plans
having raised serious ethical questions
and it's hardly a comfortable position
for the government to be in to be
criticized by the archbishop
by this particular archbishop on easter
sunday under the plans the approved
refugees will stay in rwanda whilst
their refugees
applications are processed and they
won't come back to the uk if those
applications are rejected
they will be deported but we've already
seen this morning a number of uh asylum
seekers coming ashore into dover that
means they would have left calais left
the beaches of northern france very very
early this morning perhaps traveling
through the night usually we see um
asylum seekers coming ashore mid-morning
so the fact they've already arrived it
is quite something and we've just seen
them being taken to a processing center
what we assume is a processing center
just behind one of the buildings behind
me
and that is the current plan border
force officials go through their
paperwork it's then they're then held in
small holding centers across the uk it's
there they can apply for asylum seekers
status and then perhaps wait for that
refugee status which could take years
but the home secretary and the prime
minister very much defending their plans
uh this morning but this is an issue
that is not short of controversy
absolutely no it will be discussed all
through the week ash enough for now in
dover thank you for that
now the first minister of scotland
nicholas sturgeon has been reported to
police after apparently breaching her
own covert face mask laws now she was
filmed inside a barber shop in south
atlanticshow mingling with customers and
even
patting one on the head nice trim the
incident happened on saturday when it
was a legal requirement to wear face
masks indoors in scotland now a
spokesperson for miss sturgeon said that
she soon realized her mistake and put a
mask on immediately
well those laws in scotland change from
today masks are now no longer compulsory
on public transport shops and other
indoor settings including barbers if
you're not showing symptoms in scotland
you no longer have to take routine
lateral flow tests this includes for
those at school and universities and as
of today people in scotland will have to
pay for lateral flow tests from
pharmacies or supermarkets
let's have a look at some other stories
that are making news this morning and at
least three people have been shot by
police during protests against a
far-right group in sweden riots broke
out across the country in recent days
after a danish far-right politician
plans to carry out a burning of the
koran in various towns and cities
police investigating the murder of the
journalist lyra mckee have appealed for
information about her killing on the
third anniversary of her death thirty
arrests have been made and nine people
have been charged three with murder and
six with public order offenses the 29
year old was shot and killed in derry in
april of 2019 as she observed writing in
the cregan area
hundreds of russian and bella russian
truck drivers have been stuck in a
50-mile long queue at the polish border
as they tried to leave the eu earlier
this month the eu introduced sanctions
banning trucks operated by russian or
belarusian companies from entering all
remaining in the block the drivers were
facing weights of up to 36 hours to
cross the border on saturday those wait
times are now thought to be about half
that it's not quite a long time
now talking about a long time how long
is too long to party
police in dorset called time on an
illegal rave last night 21 hours after
ordering those at the site to leave over
a thousand people descended on the area
in the early hours of sunday with the
event lasting throughout the day the
police cordoned off roads and ordered
people to leave under the public orders
act but people kept on partying until
around 9 00 pm so we'll hope we've got a
couple of days off to recover
now officials in shanghai said that
three people infected with covert died
there on sunday the first deaths from
this outbreak of the virus the city has
conducted more than 200 million tests
since the 10th of march in an effort to
curb china's biggest outbreak since the
coronavirus was discovered there in
wuhan back in 2019.
now thousands of people who joined the
coven 19 vaccination program here in the
uk have taken up permanent roles within
the health service new figures from the
nhs show that 11 483 people who helped
deliver coronavirus jabs have now
started a new career
now there is a warning from ukraine's
president that russia is attempting to
destroy the donbass and to wipe other
cities in the region off the face of the
earth our correspondent mark stone has
been to the region and has seen the
devastation first hand
we'd only been on patrol with the police
for a few minutes and we were turning
around already
the shell was in the distance but close
enough
and so it was back to their makeshift
base a location they don't want us to
reveal
the second impact seem closer
it's from the bomb shelter that they
deal with multiple challenges these
officers were the first responders to
the attack at the train station here
just over a week ago more than 50 people
most women and children died
but it's more than just russian shells
they look for saboteurs who are in this
town and sending images of potential
targets to the russians on the other
side
we've been in here for about 15 minutes
but the the police have said we've got
the all clear now so um we can head on
back with their patrol
lieutenant colonel sasha mahlish is just
29 and he's in charge of the patrols
here and in the neighboring town
this apartment block was destroyed in
one of the attacks a bomb or a missile
from a plane he told us do you know how
many people died
did
the train station is in the center of
this place where now only half the
population remain the rest have left the
station is not the evacuation point
anymore though not since the mayhem here
there are moments to be thankful for
though this kindergarten was hit but the
children were not inside the attack on
the train station down the road rightly
caught the world's attention but what's
clear driving around this town is that
it was just one of so many attacks all
around is the devastation of a daily
russian bombardment
and of course with every building hit so
many more around are damaged
probably repairable but who knows when
on the road out of cremators signs of
the battle beyond broken vehicles towed
back
fuel tankers heading forward
the city of sloveansk is a symbolic
prize for russia it was the first place
the russians captured in the 2014 war
this time it's proving harder
most of those who live here have now
left but some remain and outside the
shuttered supermarket we met the flower
sellers of slaviansk russia ukraine
rodney abracion
[Music]
then for the fifth time since sunrise
the sirens sounded again
it forced our meeting with the mayor
down into the shelter
is the only place in the region from
where people can now get a train out
and on platform one the cruelty of this
war
the 430 to la vive in the west of the
country
is a train full of the most vulnerable
the price of one man's war
mark stone sky news in eastern ukraine
joining me now is the energy and climate
change minister greg hansa good morning
to you minister and a happy easter thank
you for being with us let's just pick up
if we can quickly on what we saw there
in that reporting i mean after all we're
seeing in russia and ukraine uh
committed by russian forces at the
moment how difficult would it be to try
and have any kind of negotiated
settlement at this stage do you think
for the british government especially
with the fact that boris johnson has
been banned from going to russia
uh well look and the most important
thing is for vladimir putin not to win
this war uh we're not talking about
negotiations we're talking here about
supporting ukraine uh making sure that
ukraine's got the ability to defend
itself and britain has been right at the
forefront in making sure that military
equipment reaches ukraine and the
ukraine has a full set of sanctions on
russia and those in charge in russia
to make sure the pressure is brought
economically on russia so that is the
priority making sure that putin doesn't
win this conflict
uh okay thank you minister thank you um
mr hands now let's pick up on um the
plan to send asylum seekers to rwanda
the archbishop of canterbury over the
weekend called the plan ungodly is he
wrong
well look i think what others the
critics of this plan need to do is to
show what their solution would be you
know we have a position now where last
year 28
500 people across the channel illegally
into this country
that compares to just 300 in 2018. this
is a growing problem uh we've taken a
bold and innovative measure with this
agreement with rwanda to take action
here and i think the british people are
in support of that
i mean you're not expecting the israeli
category to come up with policies how to
deal with migration but it's the point
he's making isn't it that we are in his
words outsourcing responsibility which
doesn't fit with christian values he's
not wrong about that is he we are
outsourcing our responsibilities no
we're not this is an agreement between
two sovereign countries the uk and
rwanda
where rwanda with its uh
very good track record on taking
uh refugees asylum seekers um the uk uh
it's a it's a solution it's an
innovative solution uh it's not entirely
without precedent other countries have
done similar things in the past and it's
uh the government taking action here as
i say there's 28 500 people last year
moved from one safe country to another
illegally 27 people died it's about
taking the tough action uh particularly
on the people smugglers and those who
are profiting
from human misery in this human industry
we're making sure that that industry
gets clamped down on
and making sure this problem gets
brought under control
i mean the critics of this policy will
say that it's unworkable as we're
talking minister we're seeing pictures
of people who've crossed the channel
this very morning hundreds in the past
few days i mean do we really believe
that planning to send them to rwanda
would stop these small boats trying to
get across wouldn't they just take the
chance and see that uh british
bureaucracy probably wouldn't work
well we've backdated the policy to
january so anybody's arrived illegally
since january
with the exception of unaccompanied
children face uh being moved to rwanda
and i think that will be a significant
deterrent particularly on those people
smugglers who are profiting from these
huge numbers of people making the
illegal crossing from france to the uk
what about the cost to the british
taxpayer putting on charter flights to
send people to rwanda well it's already
costing a lot of money um the status quo
so we need to make sure that
we have a cost-effective and
humanitarian solution to this but most
of all i want to bear down on the costs
of those who are paying the people
smugglers those the people i want to
make really unhappy with this policy are
those people profiting
from human beings trying to move in this
way and that is i think uh the cost that
i would like to see come down is those
people smugglers being put out of
business i mean what does this tell us
about the breakdown of relationship
between our government and the french
government millions of pounds were sent
to france to try and stop these people's
mothers putting people onto boats and
now we're planning to send the people
that still make it into the water to
rwanda not doing very well in dealing
with the french are we well a very good
constructive relationship with france as
our nearest neighbor um and that will
continue but this is a separate
agreement uh with rwanda uh trying to
find a solution twenty eight thousand
twenty eight thousand five hundred
people crossed the channel illegally
into the uk last year as i said that
compares to just 300 only five years ago
so that is a hundred fold increase in
the number of people moving the
government is taking tough action here
and sending a very clear message that it
won't be possible um to uh
um go through those people smugglers um
and uh
and and we will make sure that the uh
the border is defended we put also the
armed forces in charge of uh the
ministry of defence in charge of the
whole operation uh as well
so those 54 million and plus that was
going to the french government to deal
with migration will still be being sent
do you think as this policy goes forward
well look we'll have to see what happens
in the future but there is no breakdown
in our relationship with france this is
about our relationship with rwanda it's
part of a wider
deal with rwanda making sure that those
numbers of people stop coming to the uk
uh and if they do come to the uk uh
they'll go to rwanda
so you talk about border being defended
you're quite happy with the royal navy
being the ones that are going to be
turning these uh small boats back yes
well we've come to an
agreement that the mod will take charge
of the channel operation
and that is uh that is entirely as you'd
expect the government to be doing to
take making sure that the tough measures
get put in place
uh that we
clamp down on those people smugglers and
this appalling industry 28 500 people
moved uh to the uk last year illegally
across the channel
now talking of of tough measures you
know that it's a a rule that if a person
misleads parliament they should resign
the prime minister has found to have
misled parliament should he resign
look the the prime minister will be
speaking to parliament in parliament
this week parliament returns
tomorrow
and the prime minister will have his say
in parliament uh and uh will uh outline
uh his version of events and uh uh and
face questions from mps and his version
of events mr hans is not exactly a
full-throated backing of the prime
minister there in your words what if we
see in the coming days pictures of him
pouring drinks perhaps at a party would
that be enough him to resign
well look i do strongly back the prime
minister i think the prime minister is
getting on with the job he's delivered
and the government has delivered and
anything for the vaccination program
through the strong support
uh for ukraine um there is a police
investigation um going on and we'll have
to see what develops but as i say the
prime minister uh will be in parliament
this week uh explaining and facing
questions from mps about what has
happened
i mean you sound still a little bit
open-minded about what may come with
this mr hand so i've put to the
question about perhaps pictures
emerging what would it take for you to
see we know that the prime minister had
a fine what if he gets another fine for
having broken lockdown rules would that
be enough for you to call him to resign
well look i'm not privy to the police
investigation uh and i think we'll have
to see
uh what the police investigation um
throws up but i strongly support you
reserving judgment then still i begin
one you're still reserving judgment then
as to exactly what you think should
happen to the prime minister in the
coming days if more revelations come out
about him having broken lockdown rules
well i don't want to prejudge um the
ongoing police investigation
what i have been clear on is the prime
minister will answer questions uh from
mps in the house commons this week uh
and we'll explain um his his version of
events and that i think is entirely
proper but there is an investigation
going on by the police and we'll have to
see
um it run its course i mean the problem
is though mr hans his version of events
hasn't always been truthful has it he
said he was ambushed by cake we know
that he turned up to that party for
maybe 10 minutes not ambushed at all
there's now rumors that he was pouring
drinks and leading toast it wasn't a
party until he got there his version of
events doesn't always stand up to
scrutiny does he well i disagree uh but
as i say he'll be explaining in front of
mps um this week
and i wouldn't want to pre-judge an
ongoing police investigation
okay mr hansen you you've made that
clear let's speak to you again once
we've heard what the prime minister has
to say
and now since you are with us on this
easter monday i do want to talk to you
about the reason you you've joined us
there are government plans here to make
sure that savers are protected when they
put money into christmas saving funds
tell us about that please well savings
clubs are something that's been around a
long time uh about four percent of the
uk population participate in savings
clubs these are where uh you put money
in to save for a big event it might be a
christmas it might be
uh planning for a funeral um these kind
of things
and we're putting in measures to make
sure that uh people who put money into
these schemes are protected either
through uh insurance or trust schemes
it's up to the scheme organizer to make
sure that those consumers those
customers are protected it's part of a
wider
package that we're introducing this week
on consumer protection and making sure
the savers in particular are protected
now ukrainian authorities have condemned
russian artillery attacks on cities in
the northeast and the continuing siege
of the southern city of madripol of
which moscow claims he's taken almost
full control of joining me now to
discuss the situation in ukraine the
former chief of the general staff for
the british armed forces general lord
danette so good morning to you lord dan
thank you for being with us this morning
happy easter to you let's
focus in on mario paul if we can for now
we understand that there may be up to a
thousand ukrainian soldiers holed up in
the steel works there i mean what are
their options from here they've been
asked to surrender they said that
they're not going to
well good morning um i'm afraid that um
remaining garrison in mario poll they
don't really have very many options um
it's according to all reports that one's
hearing they're running very short of
ammunition and i think the ukrainian
forces generally um are not able to
resupply them
so uh i think it's only a matter of time
before mario paul completely falls under
russian control um as we heard over the
weekend the russians did offer some kind
of surrender option which the ukrainian
forces have chosen not to accept so i
i'm afraid um this is going to be
a
very gruesome um
and sad ends to an heroic fight by those
ukrainian soldiers but it's going to end
i think probably sooner rather than
later with mario paul completely falling
under russian control and then of course
the russians would have achieved one of
their strategic objectives which is that
land corridor from crimea through mario
paul to the donbass region
so uh lord dana you think it could fall
within the next few days i understand
from what you said and and this then
sets up that contiguous land corridor
that the russians have been looking for
just explain to our viewers
what that will mean for the russian
forces and their prosecution of this war
going forward
well securing a land corridor from
crimea which viewers will remember was
seized by russia
in 2014
but crimea hit the two has been only
accessible to the russians by sea
now that they have almost completed
seizing a land corridor
from crimea through mario paul uh to the
donbass region which of course links
with russia proper they will then have
joined up the dots if you like between
crimea and russia proper but in a sense
this is
something of a sideshow now although an
important one and an important strategic
objective of the russians what we're
really what we should be focusing on
is the russian likely significant attack
from the east pushing west to secure the
two provinces of luhanskan diets and the
and the shelling that's been widely
reported over the last few days right
across
ukraine i think one has to see that as
being part of a preliminary operation by
the russians prior to launching their
ground defensive uh in the east
uh and lord anna i wonder if you can
react as well uh this morning we've
heard of at least five missile strikes
on la viv that's of course in the west
of ukraine it's a place where many
people have fled to on their way out of
the country what does that tell us do
you think about perhaps the change in
tempo of the russian invasion
well i think what that does tell us
is that the
russian attack in the east that i was
talking about just a moment ago uh is
being properly prepared for this time
what we saw right at the start of this
conflict that uh strike haphazard strike
south from belarus towards kiev was a
very uncoordinated operation which as we
all know
ultimately failed
vladimir putin has put general alexander
vornikov uh in charge of
operations uh in ukraine and he is
preparing this major strike in the east
striking from the east towards the west
and as part of the preliminary
operations for that ground maneuver
we're seeing artillery strikes across
the length and breadth of
of ukraine even as far to the western
city of lev
now
this is for two two reasons one is
probably to continue to try and
undermine the will of the ukrainian
people i think that'll be largely
unsuccessful as their spirit is is quite
fantastic but secondly i think the
russians are
targeting
um military hardware depots factories
are trying to erode and reduce the
capability of the ukrainian armed forces
to resist their strike when it comes in
the east so i think we see the cruise
missile strikes the artillery strikes
right across ukraine as being part of
the
softening up if you like the preliminary
operations before the major land strike
which will occur
sometime in the next few days or weeks
yeah and obviously the west is where any
resupply of ukrainian forces will be
coming in from so there are some high
value targets there for the russians to
hear
now
richard danner i wonder if we can just
pick up a little bit so i know it's
slightly out of your area but i will
hope that you have a thought on this
boris johnson's been banned from going
to russia we've heard vladimir zelinsky
saying that um depending on how mario
paul plays out for his fighters that'll
be the end of any uh negotiations with
russia i wonder
how would we even get into the
the possibility of having ceasefire
negotiations at this stage with someone
like vladimir putin is prosecuting the
war in this kind of way
well you ask a very good question and i
think
early in the conflict
i think there were very reasonable hopes
that sooner rather than later and this
of course hasn't happened
that both parties would realize that
neither is going to achieve their
military objectives very quickly and
that some form of ceasefire leading to a
peace agreement could be could be
arrived at by negotiations and both the
israelis and the turks are trying to
facilitate such conversations which
really have got have got nowhere
i think we have to accept that this is
not going to be a conflict that's ended
in days and weeks it's going to be a
conflict that grinds on
for
months and possibly years
both sides have now
lost too many civilians too many
military
deaths to easily and quickly get up
to give up the ukrainians desperately
want to continue the fight and and be
successful and vladimir putin has got to
have some kind of success that he can
report to his people
so i think what we're going to see going
back to what i said a few moments ago
is having achieved that land corridor
from crimea to the donbass we're then
going to see this
meticulously prepared i think this time
attack by the
russians into the donbass region to
secure those two provinces and then
threaten to move further west
and i'm afraid that the russians having
captured those areas in the east having
captured that land corridor will not
want to give that up and it may well be
that over the time ukraine may have to
accept that it's lost part of its
territory russia will not easily give up
that territory and frankly why should it
who can make them do so and nato is not
going to make to mount a major operation
and throw them out and if the ukrainians
can't and it may well be an ask too far
for the ukrainians to throw the russians
out then this may well become a
stalemate
over a period of months and years
whereby the russians have controlled the
east have controlled that land corridor
and the ukrainians are left with about
85 percent of their territory that may
be where over time this thing will wind
up
okay general uh lord richard danette do
appreciate your expertise and time this
morning so thank you very much
for being with us
now a number of high-end british
businesses are starting to feel the
pinch of the government's ban on luxury
goods being exported to russia they've
also been affected by the assets freeze
imposed on a number of super rich
russian saudi charges been speaking to
some of the businesses in london which
have been affected
sanctions a bit like this piece of art
can split opinion at this gallery in
london's mayfair the director suggests a
ban on exporting luxury goods may punish
the wrong people
the one or two individuals russian
individuals that i've spoken to have
you know condemned the war and and have
been
um quite vocal
alone says there are ways around this
ban
the wealthier russian clients that we
know
will have
multiple homes all over the world
and if as i understand it the ban is
just on luxury goods
entering russia
um i think it will be fairly
uh
it'll be a fairly useless
um
ban because they will simply buy the
goods for other homes around the world
uk exports to russia were worth 193
million pounds in january alone and 3
billion pounds in all of 2021.
it is an important point of principle
that we send this signal to putin's
kremlin that they cannot be living this
mayfair lifestyle in moscow whilst the
atrocities continue in ukraine
but the government also has to put in
place appropriate support for those
businesses that are affected to ensure
they can find new markets for their
products
the list of items included in the ban is
vast from high-end fashion to musical
instruments luggage sports equipment and
even horses
britain isn't alone in this the g7
countries and the world trade
organization are all working together to
further isolate russia from global trade
the idea is to ensure russia doesn't
benefit from the rules-based
international system that they say it
doesn't respect
some businesses didn't wait for it to be
official we took a stance quite early on
to stop dealing in russian diamonds and
to stop that in any way that we could do
the uk has already sanctioned
high-profile russian individuals phased
out russian oil imports and imposed
additional tariffs on the import of
russian goods and this the latest
measure aimed at starving president
putin's war machine sadia chowdhury sky
news
all right let's uh have a look at the
morning's papers again now we'll bring
in the journalists north janelle aldrid
and the journalism broadcaster thomas
copeland who i'm pleased to say there
they are big faces in the wall joining
me again at janelle and thomas thanks
for being with us all right uh let's
pick up with you uh with the front page
of the times uh we had a little bit
there from the minister greg hans and
also from ashlander down in dover this
is a
pretty patel sort of striking back
archbishop um justin welby criticizing
her plans i mean in the american
parliament she's really doubled down on
this policy hasn't she
she really has and in this joint article
with the rwandan foreign minister she
calls the plan she bolds she says
they're innovative
and you know they want the first flights
to leave next month with a back dated
policy to the first of january for
transporting um asylum seekers to rwanda
for them to be processed there and to
receive you know the news of whether
they're successful or not in rwanda um
she says it's surprising that critics
like the archbishop of canterbury hasn't
come up with a better plan well i think
most of us will say well really that is
her job to come up with the plans and
also to have alternative plans and when
they talk about the suffering of asylum
seekers um we have to ask well why are
they suffering when they come to seek
asylum here in the uk what's so bad
about them seeking asylum here they're
suffering so much that we need to send
them to rwanda for a better experience
what experience are we giving people
seeking asylum and anyone can seek
asylum and can come here and seek it and
then they will be rejected or accepted
and that will make them um here legally
or illegally so i think the other thing
that the government's doing is they're
conflating terms about illegal asylum
seekers and that just muddies the water
of public opinion too about whether or
not people should be seeking asylum here
and of course this is what the
archbishop of canterbury is saying is
that as a christian country or a country
founded on christian principles more
shall i say um we should be accepting
asylum seekers here and we should be
looking after people with compassion
when they come and seek asylum they
should be processed here and then we
will know whether or not their claims
are legitimate and i think that he is
right for speaking out in a in a sense
where the church is
some people say losing relevancy you
know he is speaking up on the issues
that cut to the core of human compassion
um so and the other thing that i fail to
see they talk about stopping traffickers
i don't think traffickers are going to
be advertising to people giving them
money that they won't actually be
processed here it's going to be in
rwanda so i don't see also how this plan
stops that but prissy patel is doubling
down and i think a lot of people will
say that she's very wrong and strong
okay thank you you know all right let's
move on to the front page of the
financial times if we can now and thomas
you picked up the the main story there
this is a chris delena giorgiova the
head of the international monetary fund
saying that uh we're facing stagflation
as a result of the russian invasion of
ukraine tell us more about that
well these are going to be the big
economic impacts from the conflict in
ukraine expected over the course of this
year
twin perils as the financial times put
it a slow growth and high inflation
stagflation expected to hit the global
economy imf says they're expecting to
downgrade forecasts from most advanced
countries around the world in the coming
week particularly in europe with its
kind of proximity to the conflict in
ukraine and really i think that you know
the reason this is important is because
this is the big challenge in terms of
you know the everyday lives of people in
the west it's going to be
the individual economic impact that it
has and the question for you know us in
the west is stuff like um you know how
much are we prepared to take and what
kind of sacrifices is the west prepared
to make in order to for example win
itself off russian energy supply rapidly
reducing that reliance on the cheapest
energy that is available comes at a cost
ethical foreign policy comes at a cost i
think for years the uk the eu the usa
have perhaps got a little bit too
comfortable with the idea that you could
simultaneously get for example energy or
anything else at the cheapest available
price on the global market and then
simultaneously go out and say well
here's the way the country should act
and here's the kind of foreign policy
that we want an ethical foreign policy
that we want to promote to other people
the reality is and we see it really
clearly in russia is that those two
things are simply incompatible
the government and you're finding this
particularly in europe and germany for
example cannot on one hand say we need
to
condemn the actions of russia and
ukraine and simultaneously be funding
that russian war machine by by
maintaining reliance on russian energy
and by removing yourself from the
cheapest energy available that comes at
a cost and that cost unless it's
mitigated by a government hits consumers
and it hits the lowest paid and it hits
the people who spend the highest
proportion of their income on stuff like
energy gas electricity petrol so you
know these this is going to be the
long-running challenge for the west and
it's interesting because you sort of see
in in the package that you played
immediately prior already these
questions of uh you know luxury goods
and why are we banning luxury goods
going to russia and they have a lot of
sympathy for business owners for example
who are seeing their businesses being
impact by the fact that their access to
the russian market is being restricted
but this is this is the reality of
trying to have an ethical foreign policy
which is reducing overall an economy's
reliance and integration
on on the russian economy for example
and the cost of that will hit individual
businesses and these are the sacrifices
that countries have to make if they want
to have an ethical foreign policy i
suppose the question for us in the west
is for how long are people going to put
up with that before you know and maybe
i'm being cynically tragically they
start to think oh well you know my bills
are really high actually i'm never going
to encourage the government to get back
onto that cheap russian energy that's
the big question for everyday consumers
in the west yeah it's a tough one to
answer as well isn't it thomas um all
right let's uh see if we can make
ourselves smile before we get to the top
of the hour by looking at the front page
of the star janelle you've picked that
out and the actor brian bless let's
bring it up to our viewers can see what
the front page of the star looks like on
this easter monday strife of brian and a
picture brian blessed with his big face
as the eye the top of the
the dots on the eye and the brian
janelle what is brian blessed up to he's
laying into mps isn't he
he is laying into them in a strong way
he says um that 99 of mps they want to
be film stars they want publicity
they're immature they need to grow up i
mean he really is going in on them
saying that they need it they need
mentors to succeed they need to learn
from people
and i do think he has a little bit of a
point especially around the publicity it
seems that people worry a lot about how
they look rather than what they're
actually doing um you know before mps
would have resigned over loads of things
that have happened recently there's no
way they would have stayed on because
they govern with consent and when they
lose people's confidence they feel it's
time to go and i think he's kind of
right that this government i guess my
question is for people like boris and
rishi and all of these things are
happening what are you really in this
for because if it's to govern people and
to govern them well and with their
confidence well you seem to have lost
that that you don't want to go so
actually i think he has a point that for
a lot of them this is a career it's
about publicity about their post-public
life and the money that they can earn
and so i think he does have some of a
point but i mean he does go probably a
bit stronger than i would go but yeah
definitely laying into them yeah and a
great pun is a headline as well on the
front page of the start all right let's
just finish up then um thomas if we can
we picked out a story from the inside
pages of the eye that says that the
defense secretary mr ben wallace is now
the favorite to succeed boris johnson as
the stocking rishi sooner continues to
tumble uh what's all this about and
who's done the polling
well it's interesting actually because
we were talking just earlier on about
this question of
support for boris johnson weather would
continue into a following a may election
you're likely to see a few more of these
kind of polls asking voters the question
conservative voters the general public
if boris johnson were to go
who would you like to replace him and
it's interesting because you know a
premiership and on a pm who's secure in
their position wouldn't open the
newspapers to see stories like this so
it's telling in itself that these are
increasingly the kind of questions that
pollsters are asking at the general
public
about who they would like to see
succeeding boris johnson at the moment
ben wallace is at the top of that poll
the defense secretary obviously winning
a lot of plaudits in terms of a fairly
uh well a consistent uh beginning early
on policy on ukraine a relatively
untarnished record certainly in
comparison to many of his cabinet
colleagues and second place there is liz
truss uh but but but rishi should not
plummeting is part of that story and you
know it's a lesson isn't it how quick
does politics move a month ago he was
the obvious choice tonight it's all up
for grabs certainly he's right thomas
you know thank you